all right thanks everyone for coming I'm
sure you're ready to call it a day but
hopefully we'll have a little bit of fun
today this is more of a fun talk is just
stuff that you don't normally talk about
which is old old stuff which i think is
actually still quite new I don't think
it's necessary just for old people
so I'm Scott this AUSA talk is really
what can we learn from the 1970s turns
out there's a lot we can learn and
there's a lot of stuff we haven't even
learned even though it's 40 years ago
and there's some stuff and 40 years ago
that we're still not doing so and
there's a shop fund a profit but I'm not
gonna be talking about their show very
much in store it's about other things so
this is the 1970s a photo taken in the
1970s until a very long time ago and if
I am quite old I am so old that I was
actually alive in the 1970s and this is
a photo of me down there so alright so
40 years ago a long time then talk about
four languages on maybe five languages
actually definitely five languages I'm
first going to have a very quick history
of programming languages because that's
always fun I'm going to talk about
hammers and tool kits and we need to
stop using so many hammers and then I'll
talk about the languages which are
sequel Prolog ml and small talk and
language X so let's start with a brief
history of small talk 350 of programming
languages write a language that does not
affect the way you think about program
is not worth knowing this is one of my
favorite quotes and there's so many
languages we learn you know they're
useful like Java or something but it's
not going to explode your brain so I'm
going to give a galaxy brain seal of
approval to languages that's literally
alter your brain chemistry so okay in
the 1950s it was a basically a dead time
I call it the Precambrian area there was
no many not many life forms around
pretty much everything was an assembly
language for and each mission each
mainframe had its own assembly language
Fortran came along
and what a concept we could actually
have a portable language that would run
on more than one mainframe Wow
he didn't have to memorize the assembly
code so that's a galaxy brain the first
high-level language definitely changed
the way people thought about programming
languages cobol came along shortly
afterwards and COBOL is the first
enterprise language and we've been
saddled with enterprise languages ever
since this came along 959 and Lisp of
course gets a galaxy brain because it's
the perfect language just because it's
Lisp Elizabeth's always been the perfect
language always will be the perfect
language here's the problem that listen
never really took off and there's a very
interesting essay called worse is better
by which a capable which are how you
recommend if you want to know why this
present taken over the world and see has
taken over the world
so in the 1960s stuff started happening
a bit more there are a lot more
computers around IBM and the Seven
Dwarfs they call them cuz there's IBM
and all the other ones were kind of
smaller companies
Alvar 60 the clues in the name
this is really the foundation of all of
our modern imperative program marriages
incredibly influential language
basically all modern languages
especially the derivatives of this or
more most imperative languages are
derivative this this is great quote this
is 13 years after Algol 60 it was so far
ahead of its time that it's also an
improvement on the successes let alone
an improvement on its previous I think
it's a good quote that's by Tony Hoare
so even in the 70s people still weren't
doing out all very well so basic is
another one nineteen sixty-four that's a
long time ago and what a concept their
language that beginners cues I mean
actually they designed it for liberal
arts students at Dartmouth College
obviously people who aren't even gonna
be programmers could even use it that
was how simple that's going to be PL 1
1964 it was touted as the only language
you'll ever need
right we know how all that that turned
out how many people still use Pier one
right but yet it's one of those things
it's going to be the perfect language
that solves all of our problems
I swim 1966 this is the most influential
language
that was never actually implemented I
like to think of it as like a Velvet
Underground you know nobody ever read
this paper but the people who did with
this paper went on to write other
programming languages so it's the parent
of functional languages it was their
personal anguish used indentation for a
scope so if you used to Python or
Haskell or F sharp that white space
indentation that offside rule comes from
I swim so super super important APL this
is the first right only language as
famous for that but actually it's not
people make jokes about APL but in fact
that the point was that mathematicians
think in symbols they don't think in
terms of words so why not have a
language that is the same kind of
symbols that mathematicians would use so
notation as an aid to thought the idea
is the new notation reflects the way you
think so that's actually a very
important concept and the Ken Iverson
who wrote APL actually got a Turing
Award for it so a PL gets a galaxy ring
because if you learn APL or a modern
version like engineering or something it
will definitely change the way you think
about programming similar 67 which came
out in 1967 first language with classes
and heritance and all the stuff that we
used to nowadays we would think this is
very kind of run-of-the-mill but at the
time there's a quite a radical concept
all other stuff so similar gets a galaxy
brain but AG actually brain stuff going
on because this is a very first time
that these things that happened BCPL
infamous is the first language is curly
braces so I hate curly braces and so I'm
gonna blame BCL Musa po4 that it is the
grandparent of C and so C took a lot of
bad habits from that poor people right
logo now if you think having you know
English students learn programming is
pretty advanced how about having
children learn programming so logo was a
language design for children this is
that in those days they still using
mainframes
right so they're using mainframes and
they're expecting children to program so
it's the idea is that programming
actually changes the way you think it
helps
interact with the world and if the
children learn to program it would help
them to be better human beings
that's not something true anymore Algol
68 so another version of alcohol very
influential as well very very complex
wasn't really didn't really take off
like alcohol 60 did so we come to
nineteen seventies now this is a decade
where I think computers are becoming
cheaper in a lot more programming
languages invented and more importantly
a lot of programming paradigms were
invented this is where we see all the
modern programming paradigms kind of
come into fruition so the first one is
fourth a first concatenative language
very interesting you get a galaxy brain
if you use fourth again it will change
the way you think about programming
there's an interesting book called
thinking forth which I highly recommend
about how to write program it's actually
available for free as a PDF download but
it was the first book as far as I know
that used the word factoring as in
refactoring it's a way of thinking about
breaking things into small pieces Pascal
which is like Algol for the rest of us
really it was kind of simpler and faster
still popular see of course you've
probably heard of that one which is
still going strong prologue so Prolog is
the first language of the first major
language that introduced another new
paradigm which is logic programming
again if you learn how to use Prolog it
will really do some mind-expanding
things your skills I'm actually going to
talk about that later on ml which also
introduced a new paradigm which is
functional programming a lot of
groundbreaking stuff going on and we'll
talk about that in a minute
sequel is another one so sequel
introduced a whole new paradigm of
relational programming and it came along
with the first relational database but
the concept of actually programming
interactive queries using a standard
query language is very radical so you
can actually praying for that CLU
another important language with
absolutely
types iterators exceptions again most
modern languages our debt to seal you
the person who who worked on that with
her team as Barbara Liskov and you've
probably heard of the Liskov
substitution principle so that's where
that comes from another one which a
scheme which is another version of Lisp
for the rest of us who didn't like
Common Lisp actually communists in this
respect then but you know Microsoft
basic so what a concept you can actually
program your 16k microprocessor using
basic pretty radical that you have a
personal computer actually sat on your
desk quite incredible really and you can
program it amazing so small talk which
went through various variants 1972 but
1976 was a big one in 1980 was a really
big one
amazingly important language the first
language of the interactive IDE it had a
virtual machine in herre garbage
collection we'll talk a little bit
definitely many many many galaxies
brains to small talk and I recommend
anyone learning should learn small talk
even today because again it will change
the way you think about programming
smarter people like to call this real
real as opposed to the soft simular know
that we used to with Java and c-sharp as
on what's also interesting about small
talk is the X practitioners are very
very influential if you look at the Gang
of Four patterns that has small talk
this is example the XP community the
agile people the reflection people these
are all people who came from small talk
so a small talk was very very
influential in the way of thinking about
programming modular - I like to call
this the golang of the 1970s it was
meant to be small and very fast and it
had concurrency built in and all the
kinds of things that people say about
dough today you could probably say that
about which of the two so they're a very
nice language and finally what language
X a mysterious language they're not
going to do what it is it scrapes into
the decades it came out in November 79
and it's the grandparent of the most
popular programming language ever so
that's a clue and I think it deserves
the galaxy brain because it changed the
way people think about programming as
well so if we look at the important
programming paradigms we've got the
imperative procedural which came from
our Algol we've got object-oriented
which came from similar and small talk
we have functional programming it's
comes from our ml we have symbolic
programming from the various lisps we
have logic program from small talk we
have the Katniss program from fourth
these concepts all originated in the
1970s 40 years ago every single major
programming paradigm that we're familiar
with is 40 years old at least
so there you go it's kind of shocking
really
and of course when I say the 1970s a lot
of these things they did take a while to
settle down I mean ml is dated to 1972
but it didn't really send us stabilize
until the early 80s small talk didn't
really stabilize into the early 80s you
know the Lisp and so on in the early 80s
so it's not quite true to say they were
you know they were stable by the end of
the nineties services but they were
definitely stable by the mid-1980s so
let's make you know 1989 there's a lot
of date right so here's the question are
you caught up with a state that art from
30 years ago
you know how familiar with you all these
paradigms and I would say most
developers have really not much you know
we're not even caught up with the state
of the art thirty years ago most people
that I'm familiar with which is kind of
sad now I'm gonna switch topics now
let's talk about DOI so if you're a
dealer I do why person and you like to
do stuff around the house you probably
have a tool kit and probably for
hammering nails you have a hammer but
when you want to screw this in you use a
hammer right and when you want to cut
wood I use a hammer and when you want to
tighten bolts or something of course you
would use a hammer for that now of
course this is not true you wouldn't
you'd have different tools for different
situations
no person but there
hammers for everything so let's look at
your programming toolkit for domain
modeling use a hammer for business we'll
use a hammer for querying data use a
hammer for live coding use a hammer and
fortunately most of us use the same
programming language for many many
different things and I think a lot of
that is because we're not even aware of
other programming languages that didn't
have a different way of doing things it
might be that another programming
another programming language is much
much better for doing certain things but
you don't even know it exists so that's
part of the point of this talk is to
improve or at least get you aware of
some other paradigms and you know maybe
change you know add some extra tools to
your toolkit so if you think about the
property of a popular programming
languages right now we have Java and
JavaScript and then I know that all
these things right they're all the same
language you might think that Python and
Ruby and Visual Basic are different no
they're different dialects but the
fundamental concepts that they are based
on which is imperative stuff with loops
and mutable variables and stuff they're
all exactly the same so we really do
ourselves a disservice when you say we
know quite a few languages and we
actually don't we really only know one
language with different dialects so
learning a new language from this pile
you don't get a galaxy brain if you
learn c-sharp and you already know Java
I'm sorry they're basically the same
language I mean if I was saying oh I
speak three languages I'm a polyglot you
know I speak British English and I speak
American English and I speak Australian
English it's like oh no I don't know
three languages I know these dialects
but I don't really know three languages
I can't speak you know Chinese or a
Native American language or an African
language those are really different
languages you know and those are the
kinds of things we should be learning as
developers so you know it's a big world
out there
there are lots and lots of different
languages are there lots of different
paradigms out there and we really should
get away from the boring CNC sharpen job
with the world and explore go out and
try and some different things so let's
go exploring let's start with sequel so
sequel was pronounced sequel originally
not SQL and it was designed as part of a
relational database the world's first
relational database now before sequel it
was really terrible every database had
his own proprietary API so if you wanted
to use a different database you had to
learn a whole new different API I mean
can you imagine if you had to learn
different API for every single database
it used in luckily nowadays when we
learn and Redis and Cassandra
stuff we don't have that problem isn't
that nice
so yes sequel is a great step forward
and I think it's very underappreciated
so there's a couple of things we can
learn from sequel as a programming
language we think of sequel as a lot of
stuff it is a programming language first
and the first thing is that the model of
the program language is consistent it's
a very consistent model everything is
relations so a relation is just a set of
tuples
you've got rows and columns so for
example if you say select the name from
a table that gives you a kind of sub
table or a subset of the data if you do
a filter sideways where you you know you
filter where the age is this that gives
you another subset of data and the thing
about these rows and columns is that no
matter what it is it's always a table
it's always a set of relations which
means that you can you know take a thing
and filter it this way and then you can
filter it this way and they you can join
them together and you know you always
get the table back and because it's
consistent you can make predictions nice
thing about consistency is I can say
well if it does this I bet it does this
too because it's consistent so if I say
well if it's set based thing I bet
there's a way of doing Cartesian
products and you say yes of course there
is its join so you do a join here's a
Cartesian product and if you want to do
an inner join its a Cartesian put it
with a filter so that's the first thing
the second thing is the sequel is an
expression based language and when a
harp on about expression based languages
all through this
so what I mean by that is everything
every thing in sequel spits out another
thing so if you take a query the output
of that query is you know a table but
you can use that table inside another
query and you can take this query and
use that inside another query so you can
embed sub queries into the bigger
queries
which means you can do this composition
thing that was going on the balance
morning you can compose bigger and
bigger queries from a bunch of small
queries very powerful technique so
expressions are composable that's one of
the great things about the expression
based languages just like there go you
could build big things and small things
so that's great
and I have a whole talk about that but
there's another reason why expressions
are great too which has got nothing to
do with composability and that's to do
with avoiding errors in your code and
making your code a little modular and
making real code easier to understand so
if I switch to a kind of a C like
language like this very simple thing I
you know I have a result if the boolean
is true then I set the results and I
create the result so how many things can
go wrong with this very simple code well
it turns out there's a lot of things
this result variable has to be
initialized before being used
so what initial values should be set to
well we assume the compiler is going to
set it something well we have no control
over that
what happens if I forget to assign the
result variable inside the if statement
do we get a compiler warning no the
compiler will say oh you've got this
result things fine no problem because I
don't have an else so if it's true I do
this but what happens if it isn't true
well I don't care the compiler is not
going to give you a warning
shouldn't it give you a warning see you
for what it you forgot to handle this
case and then the final thing is that
the the side-effects if you think about
assigning the value of result that's
basically there's a kind of not exactly
a global variable there's a variable
outside of the scope which are depending
on so it's kind of a side effect which
means we can't take this little
statement and extract it out into its
own
method ozone function because it depends
on the result thing which is outside of
the scope now if you have an expression
based version which you can also do is
see if you say if it's a boolean you see
there 42 and if it's false is there now
what's interesting is the expression
based thing solves all the problems you
can't the result thing is assigned at
the end of the expression not at the
beginning so you can't ever you know how
to say what's the default value is to
sign exactly always at when it's used
you can't you know you can't forget to
sign it there's always an elf case you
know they can't forget about the else
case and so on and because it's no side
effects you can pull that little
obviously it's a little trivial
expression but you can pull this into a
standalone sub expression very easily
you can literally refractor it by
pulling out and just pasting it in so
expressions are great for reducing bugs
and for making the factoring easier so
expression based languages are
definitely the way in the future in the
1970s that was the way of the future all
right what about sequel another thing we
can learn from sequel is it's the Terra
t'v which means you say what you want to
have happen you don't say how to make it
happen so here is some C code that's I'm
saying exactly what to do I'm saying you
need to do this this and this and this
it's all very explicit it's not at all
obvious what this code does because it's
buried in all the things about opening
files and reading from the streams like
there's some logic in there somewhere
but it's not I have to spend some time
trying to figure it out now if you look
at the what version the declarative
things they select every one where the
age is greater than 50 and I'm saying
what I want to have happen I'm not
saying how to do it I'm not saying that
you have to open the file and you have
to read these things and you have to
make that the sequel engine will do that
for you it'll take care of it you can
focus on what's important opening how to
open a file and how to relate through it
that is not important that's not
important for this particular piece of
you know trying to understand what the
goal is and because the query is
independent of the actual implementation
it means you can you can optimize the
performance in
apparently of the code so for example if
I go to the sea ship code and I want to
it's just too slow and I need to like
put an index on the file this code is
going to change it's really going to
change a lot if I have to have indexes
and stuff but this code doesn't change
at all I just add an index to the table
but my actual business logic doesn't
change so you get decoupling you get a
separation of concerns and talking of
separation of concerns here's another
thing a sequel is a query language
that's why it's called query language
it's a data pretty nowadays we'd call it
the data query language and there's a
separate language for doing updates and
inserts and there's a separate language
for doing two defining tables and stuff
now nowadays all these emerge together
into something we call sequel but they
were separate I mean they still are
technically separate languages the query
language does not depend on the data
manipulation language there's no these
languages they're separate things they
don't they're not they're not tightly
coupled with each other so what can we
learn about sequel like learn about
design from sequel learn to be
predictable expression based is great
declarative interface it's great and
separation of current concerns and also
it's interactive you can play with it
you know you can type in a query and see
what happens and if you don't like it
you can change the query and run again
you don't have to wait you know half now
while the code compiles I mean it sounds
obvious but you know if you were trying
to do this in CEO end of this in Fortran
or something you're tested like you know
compile the code and it would it would
take at least a couple of minutes I mean
maybe it takes 30 seconds but it's not
going to be you know literally
interactive the same way so what's
interesting is even though sequel is
over 40 years old and it had this
expression based most modern languages
are not an expression based sad right
Prolog next up so Prolog it was the
first mainstream logic programming
language is French and it sounds for
programmation or logic or something
apologize my French accent okay
the Americans are all into the Lisp and
the
things were into Prolog for doing AI and
it was very being in Japan
big in Japan it was so Prolog just like
sequel was also very consistent
everything is either a fact or a rule so
facts are kind of like rows in a sequel
table so here's a bunch of facts there's
this 92 Charles a 69 Charles is the
parent of wills and Charles's or the
parent of Harry and so on and so forth
so there's a bunch of facts this is just
that what the same kind of stuff you
have in sequel but in addition to that
you have rules so rule is a little thing
that says you know so-and-so is a grand
parent of a child if there's a if if the
grandparent is the parent of a parent
and that is also the parent of a child
so there's a you know hopefully
hopefully the code is clearer than my
explanation or so and so it's older than
someone else p1 is older than p2 if p1
has a certain age and p2 has a certain
age and age 1 is bigger than H 2 so
these rules now in sequel you'd have to
do these with you know store procedures
or something but in Prolog they actually
built into the language and again it's
declarative you don't tell Prolog what
you want done you say sorry you don't
say how you want to don't see what you
want them so for example I say you know
is Lee as 92 and the answers yes now if
I have an unbound variable like who
which people are 92 it prints out all
the answers and it works the other way I
say how old is this so the a variable is
unbound Anya says loses 92 and so it's
bi-directional I don't have to have two
different kinds of facts I don't have to
query one way and then query another way
it's exactly the same code so that's
kind of nice and if I say you know is
Liz the grandparent Harry the answers
yes is with the wheels older than theirs
yes of false rather who are they who is
Liz the grandparent of and again it's an
unbound variable and if I keep doing it
over and over it returns me all the
different answers so you can see it's
almost like sequel and in fact a lot of
people say well Prolog would make a
really good equivalent
which is a soft alternative to sequel
and in fact there is exactly such a
thing it's called data log so data log
is to Prolog you know what kind of a
sequel version of Prolog so let's say
I'll give you a little example let's say
we have a kind of complex query get me
the names and addresses of all the
employees that work for at least one
project located in Houston but whose
department it's not basically Houston so
it's a really complicated thing and even
in sequel you'd have to you know it be
some sort of complex Joran of different
tables and one on so in data log this is
how you'd write it you'd say we want
someone it would a nice thing about data
you make little kind of sub queries
quite nice so someone who works on the
Houston project is somebody who works on
a project and that project is based in
Houston someone who doesn't live in
Houston is an employee for the
department and that department is not
based in Houston and then we say the
answer is we want the first in the
middle of the last name and the address
of an employee who has a manager and the
manager works in Houston but doesn't
even do something so you know it's quite
a complicated query but you can actually
break it down into little pieces and you
know this is it's quite a nice quick and
a query by example model this
bi-directional unification kind of
things the prologue has is pretty
awesome
I mean if I if I there's a thing in
Prolog called pens which concatenates to
lists so you have an another you have oh
sorry it's a yeah I think it doesn't
connect to this yeah so if you can
catenate 1 + 2 + + 2 + 3 you get the
list 1 2 3 so if you say what is the
list that you get when you add 1 at 1 &
2 & 3
it gives you the answer there's only one
answer but you can put the kind of
missing variable anywhere because it
works in all directions so if you say
what do I have to add to 2 & 3 to make 1
2 3
and it's a we need the add 1 ok and then
what happens if you put multiple kind of
unbound variables okay well there's
multiple answers now we'll X could be
empty and Y could be 1 2 3 or X could be
one and why it'll be 2 or 3
or excellent me one two and why it can
be three OS will be one to three in my
could be empty so there's four different
possible answers and you'll find all
four different answers for you because
it yes this is a very cool thing I think
so let's do a prologue demo and where is
it here we go right so here's some demo
code and I'll just make it so here's the
thing I was talking about if I see
here's the parent of Harry
it's Diana and Charles you see it'll
give me all the different answers and if
I say is Liz the parent of Harry I see
no it's died another pair of the Harry
it's a true so you know that's all it is
is pretty simple but it's interactive we
can do chemical stuff with it let me
show you a more cooler thing which is
Sudoku and I'll just make that one so
hopefully we all know how to play Sudoku
now if you're trying to write a Sudoku
solver in c-sharp or Java you'd probably
work that spend a lot of time on the
algorithm of how to actually solve the
problem
in Prolog you don't in Prolog you set up
the rules you set up the constraints and
it figures it out this is the thing have
you seen you don't see how to sort you
don't see what you want to do to solve
the problem just see this is what the
problem actually is here the constraints
can you find something that matches
these constraints so I don't know
hopefully you can read theirs okay so we
say just Sudoku means there's a there's
nine rows and the second one says each
row has the same length and that each
row has a values in each row must come
from the set of numbers from one to nine
and all the rows are distinct and if you
transpose the rows you get something
called columns and all the values in the
columns must be distinct as well and if
you break the rows up into blocks which
is you know the nine different blocks we
have we also say that each block must be
distinct
so that's it that's the entire Prolog
program for solving Sudoku now we
actually haven't written any kind of
code all we've said is these all the
constraints for me now says the rules of
Sudoku it's not actually the algorithm
but then if we go and we say you know
here's a here's a problem and what we're
saying is all the all the underscores
are things we don't know the answer to
and we've got a couple of numbers in
here we know this is a three we know
this is eight and if I go over here and
I say please solve this problem and it
says oops but not there you go
so it's actually managed to fill in all
the gaps for that game because they're
the constraints uniquely define hazard
if they're worse now if I go to another
version this one here I've actually
cheat I've made it bad when I put two
eighths in the same well okay so this is
an unsolvable Sudoku
so if I go to prologue and I see trees
try and solve all the constraints for
this one then the problem of two you'll
say false it cannot find any things that
match it's just pretty cool
so obviously Sudoku sort of a a toy
problem but there many situations in
business where you know you have rules
like you find the lowest price of this
thing implies you know you have to
deliver this thing on this day in this
thing on this day what's the best way to
have the trucks drive around to do you
know constraint solving problems it's a
really really common thing in a business
and Prolog is really perfect for doing
that it's the whole way the Prolog works
so what can we learn from Prolog it's
consistent it's predictable
it's declarative again this unification
is awesome it's just a little it seems
like magic when you see how it works
really very cool ok and it's
bi-directional which is cool and it's
interactive again I didn't have to
compile stuff I could literally run it
on my own computer so you know people
businesses spend a lot of time working
on rules engines and special kind of
algorithms to solve these constant
problems like no just use prologue
prologue that's all what does it for you
and you can probably know the most the
prologue have an API you can call it
from Java or whatever it's like you
don't need you shouldn't basically
reinvent the wheel if you have this kind
of phone users at all that does it
natively alright next is ml so ml stands
for metal language not to be confused
with machine learning and it was
designed as that a theory improving
system so as an academic and a language
is an impure function language it's the
parent language full standard ml and
O'Carroll and they're sharp a whole
generation of languages are very ml
influenced there's another branch kind
of haskell branch which is pure function
languages they came from a language
called moran during the early 80s so i'm
not going to talk about functional
programming you've probably heard enough
about functional programming but I am
going to talk about things we can learn
from the ml family of languages which
are still useful today which has got
without talking about functional
programming so the first thing that ml
languages have is type inference and
this is the same kind of algorithm that
Prolog has when it does unification and
let me show you what I mean here is a
function and by the way I'm going to be
using f-sharp because the ml from 1972
is kind of hard to get hold of and it's
really not that particular thing is the
the ML influence languages that I'm
going to be talking about an f-sharp as
one of those so this is how you define a
function there shot it's got two
parameters F and X and we say Y is f of
X plus 1 and then hello plus y now we
haven't said anything about what F and X
actually are so can the compiler figure
out what's going on can it figure what
these types are and the answer is yes it
can because what it does is it says well
you're adding 1 to something so X must
be an int right if we've because you've
met anyone to it so X must be an int
similarly if you're adding Y to hello y
must be a string so Y is a string and X
is an int now F is a function because
you know
passing in a parameter and the input of
this function is an integer and the
output of this function is a string so f
it must be an integer and into string
function so there we go we've solved
we've sold this particular piece of type
inference here area into string X as an
int and the overall return value which
is hello' plus y must also be a string
so this is the kind of thing you've got
the nice thing about this is you get
codes that looks like a scripting
language it looks like Python or
something but it's actually stereotypes
and if you make a mistake the compiler
will tell you so to me this is the best
of both worlds I think type inference is
awesome right that's thing one here's a
more complex example this is c-sharp
code this is a method in the link
library group by which the return value
is an ienumerable of an i grouping of a
tiki energy source and it takes a T it
takes an ienumerable as input and takes
the func of a t source and T key but you
know I challenge you to try and figure
out what it is you know how what are all
these things what are all these types
for you know could put this way if I
told you this could you figure out what
the type signature was yourself if I
hadn't told you probably not
now the F sharp code the equivalent F
shop code looks like this there are no
type no types in the signature so nice
thing about - fizzes yeah it's less
typing you don't have to type the type
you know I don't have to type everything
over and over so it's less time but the
other things is this noise when I look
at the F sharp code I can focus on the
logic the fact that there's all these
types the C shop code has so much stuff
floating around it's kind of it's a lot
of noise in my brain that stops me
actually trying to look at what then
what's really trying to go on here so I
think that's a really important thing no
noise less noise is good and this is a
quick quote I found on Hacker News you
know type systems and Prolog have a lot
in common and people who write their own
type systems are basically implementing
a lot so they go use Prolog if you're
implementing a type system all right
number two different defaults ml
languages have in ml languages things
are immutable by default if you want
mutability you have to ask for it the
things are non null by defaults if you
want
ability you have to ask for it yeah you
get structurally quality better faucet
two things have the same data to stretch
them the same data there the safety of
their equal you don't have to override
equals and get hashcode and all the
stuff you get that for free now if you
want reference equality you can get it
but you have to ask for it it's not the
default and everything has to be
initialized right you don't have you
can't have classes where some of the
data is there and some is not so those
are really interesting defaults just
some a kind of sanity point of view I
mean they may not be that big in the
scheme of things but in order to reduce
bugs I think it's actually really really
useful these are very very sensible to
false
okay algebraic type system it's one of
my favorite topics and I like to call it
a composable type system rather than
algebraic type system and that's only
possible because the types in a
functional programming language don't
have behavior in our language behavior
and time so mixed up in function
language they aren't so by the way this
is technically the original ml
technically didn't have this but
standard ml has it and most ml languages
have this now so I'm going to call this
an ml feature so in a composable type
system you build bigger types and
smaller types in two different ways
you've either and them together or you
or them together so when you add things
together like fruit salad is an apple
and a banana and a cherry so this is
something you're familiar with this is
what we call a record type or a struct
or a tuple or something very very common
nothing surprising there but when you
all things together this is something
which is kind of unique to algebraic
type systems you can choose you can say
it's an apple or it's a banana or it's a
cherry this is a choice type I like to
call these a choice type and you write
this with a vertical bar in a shot so
these are really really useful types
because it's useful concepts because you
can you can build really big complex
types from these building blocks so
here's here's an example of how you
might do this for a payment system let's
say you accept cash
check your card as your payments and for
cash we don't need any extra information
for checks we need a check number for
credit cards we need a card type or
something
so if how would you implement this so in
a narrow language you might start off
with some base interface and you might
never met various subclasses with the
algebraic tightest thing you build it up
from small pieces with composition so
you start off with some small pieces
like this which are primitive types and
then you might say well the car types of
choice between aviso in the master cars
and then credit card information you and
it's a credit time it's a car type and
it's a card number so that's a record
type so a choice and the records and
then we build on top of those and we say
a payment method is a choice between
cash and check and if it's a check
you've got a check number and the other
choice is a credit card and if it's a
credit card you it's and credit card
information so there's a choice type and
then you can keep going keep building
and building building you can say well
payment amounts that's a primitive
currencies a choice between euros and
dollars and keep going and going say
payment is all these things it's a
amount and it's a currency and it has a
method of sale so you can you know like
a one page of code you can actually
build up really quite a complex domain
model so I think this is great and
what's cool about this is this is
executable documentation one of the
goals of the agile movement so if I show
you all these types I think you can
guess what's going on here even if you
don't even know we're short I mean this
is very you know pretty self-documenting
code it's pretty clear what's going on
even if you're non program I either
pulley figure out most of this stuff so
these are the nouns and you can also
have verbs by making functions have
types as well so this says to pick up a
card you have a hand you have your own
hand you have a card on the table that's
the that's the input then the output is
a new hand so you can you can do very
expressive stuff all the entire domain
fits on one screen and and again if you
go if you show this to someone who's not
an expert and you say
can you guess what payment methods are
accepted I think people could you know
you don't have to look in four different
files and look in the subclasses and
find out which subclasses have been
implemented there literally is some four
lines of code right in front of your
face so this is a great idea I think
it's a massive topic I have a whole talk
about de D I have a book about it so if
you're interested in learning you can
watch my talk right I'm not going to do
a demo of ML because you've seen enough
they're sharp and stuff this conference
so I don't think it needs to you what
what can we learn from ml hey it's an
expression based language what a
coincidence
so we've seen three expression based
languages already type inference is
awesome what it does is especially
allows you to work very quickly you can
add and remove parameters very quickly
that kind of figure what's going on and
it makes bad things harder to do by
having these things like things being
immutable by default it just prevents
you from doing stupid stuff you know I
think having the defaults are really
important if you have the defaults that
make it easy for you to do stupid stuff
you know you're gonna do stupid stuff
because you're lazy or you forget or
whatever if you can't do stupid stuff by
accidents you know then you're just less
like to have mistakes so I think having
proper defaults important if you if you
guys ever design an API or something
make sure your defaults are good ml was
the first language is risin though that
had parametric polymorphism the we call
generics and it of course it had a lot
of great types which are awesome right
so the type inference stuff by the way
you know the Java Java has just got var
so they've just got a feature that was
around 40 years ago
and they're still kind of worried about
it and certain languages don't even have
generics so quite certain brand new
languages that do not have generics
mentioning no names and once you get
used to algebraic types they are so
amazing for domain modeling you can't
live in a language that doesn't happen
so it's really hard to express hope that
they are all right now turn time for
small talk so which went through various
variants 1980 was the major one but I
don't even include the 1976 one because
I want to include it in the
seventies so I heart small talk very
much it was my first love as a
programming language
I spent a big chunk of my life working
on small talk and I still know that very
much and I highly recommend that you
love it too when small talk came around
a lot of people thought this is a great
way to interact with a computer this is
a teletype and you know it's a teletype
luckily no one thinks the teletypes are
the best way to interact with computers
now do they know do you think that TTY
interface is really for some reason a
lot of people think that TT wires are
still the best way we don't call we
don't have a physical thing like this we
have a console but even so we're typing
stuff in right and it's 40 years later
and we're still typing stuff in so small
talk was the idea that you use computer
should be interactive and they shouldn't
be ugly no text it should be a whole
interactive experience it was developed
at Xerox and Zurich SPARC did amazing
things they did the first PC the first
GUI the first laser printers and they're
all sorts of stuff was still up there
just incredible small talk introduced a
lot of features that we take for granted
now message-based
Aero model-view-controller a windowing
IDE a virtual machine generational
garbage collector cetera cetera magazine
many many galaxy brains this is the
small talk user interface from 30 years
ago on the Mac hasn't really changed
that much you can see it's really
interactive
obviously the bitmap was pretty low res
but we still use this kind of
interactive IDE today so first thing to
learn about small talk is it's got a
consistent model which that everything
is an object and when it says everything
object it really means everything is an
object everything everything is an
object can't stress this highly enough
the compiler is an object the stacks
frames the objects the Depot here is an
object the windows objects integers
objects
bits of everything
things love doing the other thing about
s'more - which is very interesting it
has a very minimal syntax it has three
keywords and it has only three ways of
doing I mean they say it fits on those
postcards that's how small it is and
what's interesting about that is if we
have a minimal syntax you're forced to
put power into the language when you
want to do new stuff you want to make
the language powerful enough that you
can do new stuff in the language without
having to change the compiler and this
is also part the list philosophy - if
you want to do something a list but you
want to implement objects in this you
implode it right in the Lisp system you
don't need to change the letter language
I mean interesting example of this
happened just recently with the F sharp
was a c-sharp they both introduced a
sync in F sharp they didn't have to
change the compiler because acing is the
library in c-sharp they had to change
the compiler because a sync is a
compiler keyword so and they also did it
for performance reasons no I mean I
understand but there's there's a
difference in the in the expects
passivity of you know the language all
the philosophy behind the language of
how do you add new features do you
change the compiler do you rent new
keywords or do you make the language so
powerful that it can basically do
anything without ever changing it
snorter also has late binding so late
binding means that nothing really
happens until the very last second so if
I send a message to an object to do
something I can enter in I can intercept
that message at any point and play with
it and tweak it and do stuff and we'll
see an example of that so you're going
to be a dynamic language be really
really dynamic I mean literally so
dynamic that you can change anything at
one time and finally it's more that
doesn't have text files
who needs text files everything in small
talk is in memory or the entire class is
all the engines all the compiler
everything's in memory all the time and
that means everything's accessible and
you have a lot of power and it means you
don't have to worry about where your
text files are stored you might think
well that's a lot of that takes up a lot
of memory well when I was using small
talk in the 90s it used about two
megabytes two megabytes of memory is
pretty shocking I think at Google
I wish it's a google chrome tab nowadays
like 50 gigabytes or something yeah and
I'm just saying we're worried your son
take up too much room you know compared
with other stuff we do is its trivial
now let's do the wonderful small talk
tomorrow
so I can get this oops here we go so
here's number 42 and there's different
messages you can do with 42 you can do
what you call the binary message and you
can do a unary message which doesn't
have any parameters and you can do a
keyword message where you have to pass
in the parameters so every time you see
a colon like this and small talk about
some thing with a parameter now what's
interesting is when you run this code it
puts the answer right in the thing if
the idea it's meant to be interactive so
I could then immediately start working
with it what how many was the length
will have length anyway you can start
playing with all the different things
you know on the come-on line right
obviously you have to be very careful
when you put in very large numbers
because if you do something like this
what happens is nothing happens get the
very eyes and I'll be back small talk is
designed not to break it's designed to
hide the implementation from you as a as
a user why do I care about overflow do I
care about 32-bit into us as if 64-bit
no why do I care about that so why force
me to care I should be able to do you
know very large numbers 100 factorial
should be fine
all right try doing that you know and it
takes it you know it goes all the way
down to something like what is one half
plus one third what's the answer
five six obviously so things like
fractions large numbers all this stuff
is built-in because you shouldn't have
to think you shouldn't have to say I
wonder why it's doing that one of his
overload it's like no that's never going
to happen
it hides all that stuff for me the whole
point is it's meant to the mint your
mental model is meant to be more
important than the computer model okay
now let's look at the slate binding
thing if I say 42 hello whoops it says
small integer does not understand hello
now what am I supposed to do here how am
I supposed to stop and fix the boat no
I'm actually going to go right into the
debugger and I'm gonna go to the error
message and I'm going to implement the
method right here and I'm gonna say
hello farm in DC so I'm in the debugger
I've changed some codes now if I keep
going there you go it works
so I basically intercepted a message
well wrote some code and carried on
programming and this is actually really
common in small till you actually write
a lot of code in the debugger you
basically write the code it's comes like
kind of TDD you write some code none of
it works but in the debugger you write
all the methods until it does work and
by the way which file I just wrote a new
method which file did I put the method
in did I have to sit you know I didn't
have to think about where went all right
one of the nice things about not being
at x-ray system is that it's just the
whole load of your mind you know if I
was going to do this in c-sharp yeah I
could probably fix things in the dryer
but I have to decide where am I going to
put the method which files are going to
live in there's a lot of stuff I have a
thing it interferes with the programming
this is just overhead is accounting I
don't want to think about that when I
program I just want to be able to type
stuff and have it work so small talk is
perfect for that now I said that
everything is an object so 42 of course
is an object and because it's an object
it has a class which is
small integer now small integer it's
also an object so I can say what class
are you small integer and this is I'm
small integer class thank you very much
now there's no in smaller there's no
such thing as instance methods in the
class method I mean you know static
methods and instance methods everything
is an instance method for somebody so
the class methods are actually there's a
there's a you know there's a pair of
classes that kind of main class accessor
methods but the the class methods or the
state methods actually instant methods
on another class and the class measures
that thing are actually instance methods
of another class so even go all the way
up the class hierarchy small integer
classes of type metaclasses what class
are you
metaclass met a class class what class
is met a class class class now actually
at this point you get a loop it goes
back to being ready fast but the point
is that everything is an object and I
can do stuff I say you know open up a
browser on 42 when it takes me straight
to the place in the hutton in the class
hierarchy 42 is a small integer which is
a subclass of integer which is a
subclass of number and so on and so far
all the way up and I can see all the
different methods that are available to
me for integers just an interactive IDE
just like you're used to this has been
like I said this has been around for
over but you know at least 40 years and
it's still probably one of the best
ideas out there let's talk about
creating classes so if I was a whole
person you think I'd be no you know most
other languages they have a special new
keyword so if I want to create a new
animal I reduce them like this Smalltalk
doesn't have a new keyword doesn't have
any keywords hardly the way you create a
new animal is you sent a message so you
go to the animal class and you say I
want to create a new animal
and I'm going to call it say a cat and
there it is it's a cat and if I browse
it there is this you can see it's in the
animal class and so on so everything is
a message you've created by sending
messages you know you put instances by
sending messages you do everything by
sending messages like I say everything's
object now if I want to create a new
class that was creating a new instance
how do I create a new class well the
answer is I sent something a message so
this is a message it's actually a
message with five parameters so if I
want to create an animal to class I do
it by sending a message to something I
send a message to the object class and I
say I want a sub class called animal too
and I don't need this and it's going to
have maybe a name and an age inside
there is and their mutually shows up in
their class browser so everything is
sending messages right oh yeah
and of course which file did I put this
new class in okay not just it's just
stuff that gets in the way now I talked
about not having keywords I mean not you
know not having a very simple syntax so
something like if true if false in
Smalltalk there's no if statement how do
I do if in small talk I use messages so
I say one if I say one equals one if
true what am I going to do I want to say
yes and if it's false I'm gonna say no
and that's yes and if it's like if it
really isn't true for some reason when
the same driver so this if true if false
is a message that I'm sending to a
boolean alright there's like less a so
there's no special syntax for if true or
false is no special syntax for looping
there's no special syntax for switch
statements or for I don't know think of
all the syntax you have in your favorite
language how many keywords there are in
C or C sharp as me though none of those
keywords exist in in small talk let's
look at the implementation since it's a
method we can look at it and we can also
change it if we want to if you want to
be stupid enough to change if true that
would not be very sensible there's three
different implementations of if true or
false
one is at the billion which is the
parent and there's two subclasses one
called true one called force these are
very small subclasses because they have
slightly different behavior
now the boolean definition of the method
says not my problem
it says subclass responsibility right
which is so if I try and call it I'm
going to get an error message now if I
look at the definition for the true
subclass it's going to say true it's
going to take the true block which is
you think of it's like a lambda you send
to take this block and it will just run
this block now the false implementation
is exactly the opposite whoops the false
implementation takes the false block and
runs it so if you know anything about
lambda calculus this is how language is
true and their forces implemented in the
calculus so it's quite influential and
Smalltalk anyway that's enough about
small talk because we're running out of
time so I just wanted to you know show
you that small talk is really cool what
can we learn it's got a consistent model
minimize the syntax we'll make the
language more powerful be awesome and
make people fall in love with you and
that's not a joke a lot of the first
stuff in the 80s you know the Apple Mac
they really wanted people to love it it
wasn't just a piece of hardware the
smaller people who designed small talk
really wanted you to fall in love with
it they put a lot of effort into you
know the icons and the language
and they interact the interactivity of
it so if you're designing a program you
know I think about making people fall in
love with you it's a really good thing
it will really make your program much
better okay so I'm just gonna be about
five minutes over I hope that's okay
just finish up with my mysterious
language X so a lot of people say well
you know it's small talk self-contained
it doesn't use a file system it's
interactive it's got a you know surely
it's a dead end people don't do that
kind of stuff anymore
so languages look let's look at language
X in the 1980s people pay thousands of
dollars just to use this language that's
how important it was it's descendants
have been at the heart of software
products which dominate their field and
its grandchild is probably the most
popular program language in the world
who knows what I'm talking about I bet
some people do so yeah the answer is
VisiCalc so VisiCalc came out in 1979
and immediately became incredibly
important and of course VisiCalc began
Lotus 1-2-3 which is the most important
language of the 80s and that began Excel
which is still one of the most important
programming environments now what's
interesting about Excel and visicalc and
so on it's a programming environment
right it's something where you type in
equations and you know you get the
results interactively if you couldn't
type in formulas in Excel it wouldn't be
popular so anyone who uses Excel is
programming and that's why it's the most
popular program in there it's actually a
functional programming language so why
was physic help so important and so
successful well it's got a consistent
model everything is a cell and a formula
that acts on the cell okay it's super
super interactive the whole point if you
had to compile your formulas in Excel
and wait 30 minutes before you could see
the answer it would be a complete flop
the fact that's super interactive you
type something and it shows up over here
that's one of the reasons why it's so
great
so it's an it's an interactive format
and a program it's hard to say is it a
program or it wouldn't exist without the
interactive
but the interactive environment will be
useless without the programming language
they fit together kind of you know that
this one integrated system is you can't
separate them out now just like sequel
it's the domain-specific language it's
an expression based language it's a
language that non-programmers can use by
a a 1 + B 1/2 that's the kind of thing
you could within that formula and its
functions it uses functions everywhere
so when you do some in Excel you're
doing functional programming and like
pro like Prolog you program that sort by
filling in slots you fill in all the
cells and it figures out what's going on
and of course like small talk there's no
separate text files when you save a
formula in Excel you don't say I want to
save this formula in this file no you
save it in the entire environment you
saved the entire Excel environment don't
save a particular formula to a
particular file so what can we learn
from this account
well programming it you know peers and
many guises we think of programming is
running things through C compiler
whatever you know typing in vim it's
like there's a lot more to programming
that it's making a computer do what you
want so program is not just for
programmers I mean it's a shame that it
should just be for professional programs
it really people love to interact with
the environment want to explore stuff
and programming for the particular
domain is actually a lot easier in
general than general-purpose programming
if you had if you had if Excel used to
like the C language instead of the Excel
macros whatever again it would be a
complete flop yeah so we always think of
we you tend to be think about that
everyone's just like us and we're all
into like hardcore programming you know
there's a lot of Excel programs over
there there's a lot of people who
program in other you know other systems
people just do a lot of flash
programming people do CSS CSS is a
program language all sorts of stuff you
know and use the right to of the job
don't use Fortran in an Excel program
it's not the right tool for programming
a spreadsheet you know for trainers
great for some things but it's not play
for other things Prolog is great for
something but it's not great for this
you use the right tool for the job
okay don't always use a hammer so there
are lots of different approaches out
there
get yourself a bigger toolbox and Cecil
since Isis not the only sin to all these
languages I've been talking about none
of them had a C so C style syntax even
small talk didn't have dots
there's no dotting into something in
small talk right it uses spaces and when
you end a sentence use a period or full
stop
you don't use a semicolon it's not
proper English to end sentences with
semicolons okay so you notice that
prologue and small talk use full stops
to end their statements or the
expressions no curly braces anyway you
haven't seen a single curly brace today
no dots okay so a language that doesn't
affect the way you think about program
is not worth knowing
so please please go and expand your
galaxy brain there are loads of new
languages go and change the way you
think about stuff and it'd be great for
you so off you go
thanks very much this slides video will
be on my websites and if you like my
book you can read all about it there so
thank you very much
[Applause]